you want to pick one
first I mean I haven't tried any of
these before but I guess what's this one
this is tessellation Lone Pine from
Portland Maine oh wow yeah yes yeah
every beer in Japan [__] we just got
a bunch of American crap here you I
might pick the I might pick Vegas as
[__] for this one um I'll take this one
then tessellation you're going to have
the oil of angels it's 7.7% I'm going to
be [__] up I mean these are all like
pretty bad this is 6. five so it's not
that much so much alcohol you spilled it
every all right sure I'll have the oil
of angels it's the it's a hazy Indian
paleale oil of angels is a hazy IPA brw
with spelt Ry and oats hopped with
an what what this can't be C hopped with
an ethereal combination of Galaxy Mosaic
eal Simco never
I've never thought I would describe a
beer using the word colal J mine's very
hazy yeah so do you know what the
difference between an Indian pel and a
paleale is uh one's Indian uh well
no uh I think I guess the difference is
that it's just generally just less
alcohol in a pale that's pretty much the
same same same Brewing method I know you
like I know you really like hazy uh no
PS are my favorite oh like P I like ipas
oh you like yeah I remembered one of you
really
yeah let's pour it let's [__] it up you
know I I actually saw I actually saw a
video I know I saw it too is is it the
video with like the bear expert that's
like you should you should let the beer
foam up actually everyone's like
gaslighting people into not letting the
beer foam up to be fair if you don't
want to be bloated it is a better way of
drinking beer but if you like being
bloated and you want the beer to taste
better who wants to be bloated well okay
drink okay listen I do think the beer
tastes better when you don't do this cuz
it's more carbonated and I feel like it
has a better flavor but if you don't
want to be bloated then this is the
better way all
right I mean I'm still not going to do
it listen listen I'm just I'm trying it
I'm testing it out [__] hell what's
the color Che cheers boys so we're
recording this episode this Tuesday and
it'll be out Saturday yeah so we thought
we'd do uh a timely episode okay well
timely in some sense time timely in some
sense and since Conor has another yet
another flight to catch fck to [__] off
to America again giving you the [__]
Vegas I'm going to Vegas I you're going
to Vegas you know we haven't had a
chance to catch up it's been basically
been since mood's episode right that we
CU yeah I went on the RV Tria which felt
like a year and that was like a day
because uh that was the day of recording
so I haven't had a chance to catch up
with the boys since we've been traveling
really uh so we thought hey why not uh
try a bunch of Japanese beers and uh
just catch up how was the RV trip by the
way I haven't asked yeah were you
supposed to come G I don't know ba
bailed on me really I did I did see like
just I just straight up said I can't he
said he could so you know to be fair to
be fair I was like I did genuinely want
to come uh because I came on the last
one it was like a lot of fun uh I just
had way I just you know I think the tour
put me back way more than I thought it
was going absolutely did uh because I
thought in my in my naive little mind
that I'm like I'm going to be in England
for an extra week and a half after tour
no one's going to want to meet up or
hang out I can just work in my England
house and I'll catch up to work all then
JK when you were in a [__] different
country and your family's like uh excuse
me why are you not why are we not
meeting why why why are you not being a
good family member I feel it's
especially the true for you cuz it's
like I I bet when you're back home like
you're just like your 30,000 cousins are
just like all right I mean you got to
make time for all of us yeah yeah and
also catching up with mates as well so
just I I I had planned to do a few more
working days but unfortunately well you
know you got to make time for the
friends and family and unfortunately
something had to go and it was the RV
trip I'm sorry Conor I'm sorry okay you
to me it's fine this tastes bad by the
way this tastes bad that didn't taste
good does yours taste good it's hazy
right so this probably tastes pretty
good I imagine just
sweet this tastes very
hoppy oh it's very hoppy I like that
though I don't think it's oh actually no
it's kind of sweet I don't know try this
I can TR I just don't rate it do do you
like this one I think sometimes the hazy
ones go the the in America some hazy
ones go way too hazy oh that's a bit too
sour for me yeah it's kind wa let me try
yours yours this is the kind of
car yeah it's not bad yeah American ipas
man sometimes I like them but sometimes
they're just too much it's a hit yes uh
but yeah no I um it went really well I
think I improved a lot on the first one
mhm I tried to we had like last time we
had like just one car following us this
time we had two cars so nabbi was always
going ahead and sorting everything out
out so when we got there we could just
jump right into it um Phil franker style
and um yeah but did you have fun yeah it
was really fun it was super it was super
super I I don't give a I don't give a
[__] about the technical details tell me
about the fun I missed out on con me
it's like it's a mix right Logistics if
the logistics go well I can have more
fun because then everything's going
perfectly from my perspective but but
like yeah it was it was very fun I was
yeah uh it it was uh we were in the RV a
lot less than last time but it was
really fun I think uh we had some really
fun activities I didn't think we're
going to be as fun as they they were um
like we did pottery making that was
really fun MH um D we did so much how
was the Tuk Tok driving dude that was so
fun I can't believe you would
appropriate my culture like this own
entertainment there just a dude in IU
who's just like yeah so we we shipped it
off to Japan uh to Thailand they shipped
it back in and oh my God that [__] was
impossible to drive initially yeah um
and it sounded like it was being choked
out cuz it was manual as well oh [__]
okay did you know that all Ts a manual
uh yeah oh I've never driven one but I
you know I've seen people drive it it's
like a rickety [__] car that's a manual
it's like a hybrid bike and a it's
really not fun to drive it's not fun to
be in as as well no and I was I was ABS
because it's been so long since I've
driven a manual uh and and it didn't
help that the car was also kind of hard
to drive like the the accelerator when
you pull it down it would and you let go
it would just stay oh so when wanted it
to get back down to to nothing it was
very hard to like physically keep doing
it but then also if you did it a little
bit over when it was on zero it would
start revving so I was really confused
the whole time and I I I was either over
revving or under revving constantly and
I was always in the wrong gear and the
[__] me the gear box was so [__] on it
and I couldn't do it but then I went
first sound like it was dying L did it
it sounded perfect and I was like [__]
so basically you experienced what it was
like for me when I first drove a manual
gu just absolute chaos we drove the
manual ual uh in that place when we
drove the manual cars that time I found
it really not not bad at all to drive
that but my God this TK Tok was so hard
and I was just not I guess it been so
long but it was really fun uh the Tuk to
driving actually was was a really big
cuz I didn't know what we were going to
do I just planned I took get a to and
then we'll figure it out we ended up
doing like a Kind of Crazy Taxi like go
and pick up something from the Comin and
bring it back my God being in that car
on the road is terrifying cuz just when
you would take turns it felt like it was
going to flip yeah m it's not fun um and
you could hear it from like two miles
away it always feels like you need to
treat treat it like a motorcycle you
know uh I don't know how the center of
gravity is on that [__] yeah it's a
motorcycle with like a bit of extra
width and you can have passengers for
some reason a thick motorcycle
apparently it's completely road legal as
well in Japan like the guy I mean
obviously it is because he's offering
that service but I was like I can't
believe Japan allows otherwise you would
have just committed a crime I just can't
believe it's allowed on the road I just
I was like what really I guess it's got
mirrors and indicators so that and seat
belts so that's nor like actually the
front didn't have seat belts cuz maybe
because it's a bike huh I don't
know we just like dis water is right now
seat belt I don't think it did have seat
no maybe I don't know I don't think it
would as as a tie resident I don't think
it would have a seat belt I would be
amazed if I had a seat belt on a Tuk Tuk
yeah that was uh it was interesting went
to a zoo that was fun but you would have
came and you would have done uh
canyoning which is really fun what's
canyoning uh it's where you jump off and
slide off water faults oh that sounds
fun and an easy way to get an injury but
that sounds yeah we had these um well it
was sucked cuz the stream that one day
the signal was really bad yeah I assume
you were in like the forest or something
right yeah and we normally would have
used starlink to kind of as a backup but
because it was like raining and it was
really hard to get a satellite for some
reason I can't and there was trees and
[__] so it was it was not good but um
people got to see the end which is fun
but uh I was talking to the there our
guys with this like these two Tibetan
dudes I don't know how it's always just
two Tibetan dudes always end up being
the guides for dangerous things um I
goes you look like Mr Beast and I was
like I don't I don't think I look like
Mr Beast but I I go I have this
conversation with him and I go um I was
he was tell me she's from Tibet and I
was like oh cool cool uh and he was like
do you know uh Mount Everest I was like
yeah I know Mount Everest he's like some
people don't know Mount Everest and I
was like who the [__] doesn't know M
ever I was like who didn't know what
Mount Everest was can you can you tell
me who this person didn't know what
Mount Everest was I don't believe it
he's like you should do it it's fun I
was like you mean climb ever he's like
yeah yeah I was like thought people die
on the trail I was is it like super
overcrowded and you can't do without a
show he's like maybe I was like it's
just do it like a Mr Beast challenge you
know big hill what's the worst that get
up and just keep going up I mean those
those dudes are buil death yeah don't
yeah but they're also the majority of
them are living like 4,000 m above sea
level and they just think that's nor
it's like you to them it's just like oh
it's just like a slightly bigger Hill
built born in like 10g gravity or
whatever like Goku trains in you know
and they come back one third the oxygen
level like this is fine they come back
down and you're like people breathe like
this they go to sea level and he just
like it's too much
oxygen um but it was really fun and then
right after that I went to go and watch
uh uh Tatro y I'm so [__]
jealous so good